ん2
me
ん
[音楽]
voodoo
大学4年生の6月私の人生は大きく変わりました
汗が止まらなくなったり少し歩いただけで息切れがしたり
動悸がしたりしたのです
体調不良を覚え病院に行った私は
完治することがない病気脳
バセドウ病だと診断されました
バセドウ病は首の前側にある甲状腺という機関から甲状腺ホルモンが過剰に作られて
しまう病気です
甲状腺ホルモンは体の新陳代謝を促し体の働きを活発にするホルモンです
ホルモンの量が過剰になると
寝ていてもジョギングをしていると例えられるほど体の働きが活発になりすぎてしまい
様々な症状が現れます
私は特に汗が止まらなくなる症状に悩みました
周りの人から汚いと思われたくなくて
大学では人と話すことが怖くなってしまいました
私は大学の卒業式の日のことを
忘れることができません
4月からどこで働くの
友達同士が目を輝かせながら話していました
私は先生になるよという友達がいました
ずっと働きたいと思っていたブライドルの世界で働くんだよ
そう笑顔で話す友達もいました
私も進路を決めて大学を卒業すると決めていました
ですがバセドウ病によって
就職することができなくなりました
友達同士でそんな会話が飛び交っている中
自分の進路を聞かれることが怖くて
自分は何物でもなくなってしまうことが恥ずかしくて
自分はここにいてはいけないように感じて
私は逃げるように卒業式からが入りました
私は
一番の劣等生でした
ご飯ものどを通らず夜も眠れない日が続きました
そして私は最終的に
うつ状態になってしまいました
とても辛い経験をしたり自分のことが嫌いになったり
自分に自信が持てなくなったりすることは
きっと誰しもが経験することなのだと思います
でもそんな辛い出来事の中でも私たちは幸せのかけらを見つけ出す力を持っています
バセドウ病になって以来これまで私がたくさんの人たちからもらってきたこの力を
今日は私が皆さんにお伝えできるように
このプレゼンテーションを今日のこの時間を皆さんと一緒に紡いでいきたいとおもい
ます
孤独だと思っていた私に
寄り添ってくださった方がいます
それは私の主治医の
内堀先生でした
先生は私の運命を変えてくれました
僕も大学を卒業するとき仕事が決まってなかったよ
先生はおっしゃったんです
医学部に入学するために大学卒業後何度も受験をしたこと
5年ローンに生活を送ったあと6年短大学で医学を学んだことを私に教えてくれました
就職先が見つからず苦しかった当時の私にとって
先生のこの言葉は驚くほど暖かく
私の胸に響きました
自分の弱みを見せてくれる大人がいることに大きな衝撃を受けました
先生がしてくださったことは
それだけではありません
教育や福祉や医療の世界に興味があることを話すと
どんな仕事があるか
その仕事に就くために今私にできることは何かを一緒になって考えてくれました
私はこれまでの人生の中で私のためにここまで伴走してくれロートなとで行ったことが
ありませんでした
一人じゃないよ
一緒にどうすればいいか考えよ
という先生の姿勢は
私を安心させてくれました
もう少し頑張れるかもしれないと希望が持てるようになったんです
そして私も一人一人と正面から向き合いる大人になりたい
そんな働き方をしたいと決めました
内堀先生を合わせ同病の治療してくれた人です
ですかそれ以上に
なりたい私を教えてくれた
とても大切な人です
現在のバセドウ病の治療は続けていますが資料を進める中で汗が止まらなくなる症状や
息切れがする少女も和らぎ
就職活動も無視乗り切ることができました
先生に手伝ってもらいながら私が選んだ道
それは
教育福祉の仕事でした
今主に発達障害のあるお子様と関わらせてもらっています
私は今でも内堀先生を目指して働いています
私はバセドウ病になり
就職活動がうまくいきませんでした
同級生と同じように就職できなかった私は
これまで育ててくれた両親に
迷惑しかかけていないと思い
私はここにいてはいけないんだと
考えるようになりました
私は
生きていてはいけないと
ですがこの世の中で自分の存在を否定してもいい人なんているのでしょうか
私は病気のことで自分をこれ以上否定し続けたくありません
悔しかったんです
一歩前に進みたかったんです
バセドウ病になったからこそ出会える幸せを
私は探したいです
また以前ほど汗をかかなくなった私は
人と話せることがこんなにも幸せなことなんだと知りました
これは病気になるまでは
感じることのなかった幸せでした
病気になる前以上に
人と会いたいと思いました
せ同票がきっかけとなって内堀先生という素敵な先生と出会うことができました
そしてそんな出会いをもっともっと積み重ねていきたいとおもい
私はいろんな人に入りに行く食べよう始めました
私はこれまで生き方を変えられる出会いを何度も経験しました
今日はあと2つの出会いを
みなさんにご紹介したいと思います
はじめにバセドウ病を含めた工場性疾患の患者会である
おしゃべり会に参加しました
最初はどんな場所か不安で
何度も入り口まで行っては引き返すことを繰り返していました
最後にはなんとか勇気を振り絞って会場に入ることができました
そこでは患者さんとスタッフの皆さんが円形になって座りコーヒーやお茶を飲みながら
治療を進める上での不安や心配事を話しされていました
私はそこで
これまで感じていた
悲しい気持ちや悔しい気持ちを
全て話しました
同級生と同じように就職できないことがつらかったです
誰にも相談できず
ひとりぼっちだと感じていました
両親
ごめんなさいと思って生きていました
すると同じ工場製の病気のあるスタッフの皆さんが
それはつらかったねとうなずきながらゆっくりと私の話を聞いてくれたんです
私の心配とは裏腹にそこはとても優しい場所でした
私はこの日一人じゃないんだという安心感に包まれました
そしてこれまで感じていた孤独から解放されました
本当に嬉しかったです
一人じゃないということがこれほどまで心強く
暖かいことなんだと私は知りました
またスタッフの皆さんからはバセドウ病の私だからできることがあるともナビました
つらい経験をこんな形で使えるということに私は衝撃を受けました
私もこんなふうに自分のつらかった経験を使いたい
そんな気持ちをスタッフの皆さんからもらいました
今では私もしゃべり会のスタッフの一人になり
フィフィ同じ病気の患者さんからお話を伺っています
相談室に入ってくる時に元気のなさそうな表情していた患者さんが
今日はおしゃべり会に来られて本当に良かったです
同じ病気の人の話を伺えて安心しましたと笑顔で帰っていく瞬間を見るときの感動は
本当に大きいです
こんな活動ができているのはせ雑兵になったからこそだと感じています
バセドウ病の私だからできることがあると
患者さんや仲間のスタッフから教えてもらいました
バセドウ病になったことで
病気のある子供たちへの教育についてもっと学びたいと思い
私は次に
ある講演会に参加します
講演をされたのは副島先生という先生です
先生は病院の中にあるかっけーの先生です
先生の講演が終わった後の質問タイム
一人の人工呼吸器をつけた断酒学生さんが手を開けました
僕の病気より
もっとしんどい病気の人がいるから
あ辛いとか
しんどいとかいうのは違うと思うのですが
その男の人は言いました
皆さんにも自分の気持を閉じ込めてしまった経験はありませんか
私も同じです
私自身もバセドウ病よりも大変な病気があるからしんどいと思ったらいけないと自分の
気持ちに蓋をしてしまうことがありました
質問に対する先生の答えをこうでした
相撲してくれてありがとうございます
周りの人と自分を比べなくて良いと思い
の気持ちを大切になさってください
私は思わず涙が出ました
講演会の中で先生が何度もおっしゃっていたのは
どんな気持ちも自分の大切な気持ちだということです
ライト感じた気持ちは
ありがとうも比べなくていい
つらいと感じた気持ちをもっと自分の中で大切にしてもいいそう
私は先生から学ばせてもらいました
毎日の生活の中で自分の気持ちをなかったものにしてしまうことはありませんか
でも私たちはもっとっ
自分の気持ちを大切にしていいのだと思います
私たちはもっとつらいと感じた自分の気持ちを素直に受け止めていいのだと思います
どんな気持ちも自分の大切な気持ちがと知ることができたのは
製造秒のおかげです
私は
バセドウ病です
どうしてバセドウ病になってしまったんだろう
せ投票になったから私の前世はこんなにも悪くなってしまったんだとずっと思ってい
ました
ですか汗雑兵になって失ったものよりも
バセドウ病が与えてくれたものの方が多いと私は気づきました
バセドウ病が私の人生を豊かにしてくれていた事に私は気づきました
バセドウ病だからこそ
一つ話せることがこんなにも幸せなことなんだと気づきました
バセドウ病だからこそたくさんの素敵な方々と出会いました
バセドウ病だからこそ人の幸せのために自分の命を燃やしている大人がいることを知り
ました
バセドウ病だからこそ
一見悲しい出来事が人の役に立てる力を持っていると知りました
聖堂病だからこそ
自分の気持ちをもっと大切にしてもいいんだって気づきました
バセドウ病だからこそ
この学びを教皆さんに届ける機会をいただくことができました
バセドウ病だからこそできることが数え切れないほどあると
今は信じています
皆さんはだからこその前にどのような言葉が入りますか
私はその言葉の中に
無限の可能性が秘められていると信じています
だからこそという言葉を私にくれたのは
東静脈奇形という表記のあるかは行け静香さんです
顔にも負けずという本の中で静香さんが話されていた言葉を紹介させてください
もし今の状態が保障されるなら
子供がいて主人がいていっ
顔の症状があったからこそ出会えた人たちとの関係が保障されるなら
顔の症状がない方がいいです
ただ今の自分になるために
この顔の症状が必要とされるなら
それはあってよかったと思います
静香さんのこの言葉からバセドウ病だからこそという生き方をしたいと決めました
今でも私はバセドウ病だから辛いと感じる日があります
だからこそなんて考えられないほど辛いことがこれから起こるかもしれません
でもその時その時に心に浮かんでくる気持ちを今は大切にしたいです
悲しい気持ちは人の痛みを想像する力を私に与えてくれました
悔しい気持ちは前に一歩進む勇気を私に与えてくれました
どんな気持ちもなかったものにしなくてもいいと
私は学びました
辛い頑張れないと自分の心が教えてくれた時は
そんな日もあるよねと自分の心に耳を傾けたいと思っています
これからも汗闘病になったからこそ
バセドウ病だからこそできたことや出会えた人を探し続けたいです
これまでのつらい出来事の中に
そしてこれから出くわすかもしれない困難の中にだからこそできる活動家だからこそ
出会える人をみなさんを一緒に探してみませんか
最後にもう一度聞かせてください
あなたのだからこそは
何ですか
ありがとうございました
[拍手]